special just drops so make sure you
don't run
Sprint
that's right yeah in fact there's a rail
line if there's one of those fancy
Japanese Rail lines that works on
magnets yeah get on that and go to your
local Amazon Prime Building
go up to the chairman and say I want to
watch this now unfiltered because when
you watch on Amazon Prime it's filtered
you know yeah so get on it
I'm about to kiss you I'm going to
button this with a kiss okay now if they
got a supersonic jet meaning it breaks
the sound barrier I mean it goes so fast
it pushes all the air molecules together
and they have nowhere else to go but
burst that
you do that you go watch his specials
what's it called Steve Burns special
I watched it I liked it just don't
remember the time
this is really the fighter and the kid
so Steve I just want to start this
podcast I was saying that you smell a
little bit like alcohol so I know you
weren't drinking this morning so I'm
wondering what's going on they tell you
know I'm like I thought it was cologne
you're not scared
this mess was good in here well Brent is
a heavy drinker and clearly has a
problem right yeah it's going to be an
ugly situation about five years
100 but um just stinking booze what's
going on with you I don't know you to
drink uh I don't normally I'm not I'm
not a day Drinker at all but I did
chrishers yesterday first Chrysler 11 30
in the morning
they go hey do you want an Uber I was
like why would I Uber they're like you
know why I'm like I'll take the Uber and
you go there I think I was on for three
and a half hours it was just three and a
half hours just we I think we went
through at least like a bottle and a
half we went through a few different we
finished one of them I know that what
was that whiskey oh yeah whiskey if you
drink my tiger theme
a bottle in two days yeah you see I need
more money I can't keep up dude I have
to like having a pedal I did the Jameson
Whiskey tour uh with Chrysler that's how
we you know we knew each other from New
York but that's when we really started
to hang out and so before the tour
started Jameson Whiskey sent us each a
case
um we go to the first gig it's like me
and Billy Gardell and and Chrysler and
Chris like anybody else finish their
case I'm like I've even opened it
finished the case finish the case he
finished the case this is the best of
all yeah but I I have two friends that
if if I open a bottle of whiskey like
that I'm at home
it's gone and they drink they will drink
the whole thing and they'll do this
after the fourth one they start to feel
guilty so they'll hit their glass and
they go should we uh well you know it's
always yeah yeah one more snifter yeah
just to round things off and I'm always
like whatever you want to do yeah but
I've had expensive bottles just go by
the wayside and once I'll finish this or
a bottle and I'll go anybody else
thirsty can you do that can you can you
drink a whole bottle with no no no no
I'm not that bad yeah no some people can
do it and both my friends are pretty
much sober pretty much maybe you're a
wine guy I'm a wine guy but that means
two glasses and when I'm crazy three
I mean Brian's always don't say that
what are you what's your drinking
whiskey is whiskey whiskey yes
I'm not Bert no I'm a gentleman like an
animal it went the whole day then it was
like the floodgates were open and then
it was just yeah
you don't remember doing it I did
I did I showed up an hour late for
George Lopez's podcast well that's a
problem George Lopez I'll tell you
Legend yeah it was the first time I
actually hung out with couldn't be nicer
great guy sweet guy great guy don't
really remember much just pockets of
like he's cool yeah like I see that kept
coming through my head like it's a
really nice guy now do you think he said
the same when he left
one of the great Comics period one of
the great Comics well you know what I
think is fascinating about Lopez
everything that um Conan O'Brien was
victimized for during that late night
War everything that the media said look
at what cone and Conan it actually did
happen to Lopez like Lopez is the
biggest casualty of that moment in time
with the late night Wars where I totally
forgot about that well you know the
whole thing was Conan's gonna be asked
to move back and then uh with Leno
remember he was can you go back because
remember he got like a half hour or
something I was like actually I'm gonna
come back and they pushed Conan back
right exactly yeah and then Conan ended
up getting the boot right and so Lopez
is over at TBS and he's his show is by
all metrics like doing really well he
was he was kind of like breathing a new
a kind of like almost like Arsenio to me
where he was doing these Street parties
and doing all lot of fun things and
inventive things in the space of late
night and then uh and then Conan came
over to TBS so they actually bumped
Lopez back so Lopez I think with Grace
and just being a total team player on
behalf of the network absolutely great
to have Conan here he's the lead-in and
then Lopez gets bumped back
then he starts losing viewership and
then they give him the boot
yeah and Conan was the one that stayed
so I I think everything that you read
about at the time about Conan being the
victim it's like well actually that all
actually happened
Lopez Lopez actually the one he lost it
yeah apparently Lopez grabbed Robin
Williams threw him up against the wall
really said you're doing you did half my
Act was that Robin Williams that he said
that about no I know who you're talking
about it's um
it was yeah was it Germany
I don't want to throw am I right I don't
want to beat a dead horse over there I I
can't remember who it was but I don't
think you're being dead horse I don't
think anybody's talking what quinceanera
did this occur at I think it's your
question yeah well you know you know
flea market I was watching I was
watching late night I was watching
Johnny Carson and if you watch that back
then no that was just from YouTube runs
my dad was watching the reruns the best
the best but but what's interesting is
that when you watched in your 30s
yeah you watched a movie star show up
like Frank Sinatra it was so but we
never we never heard from them you'd see
them in a magazine but all of a sudden
somebody like Robert De Niro was on
Johnny Carson sure and everybody would
tune in to see five minutes of this
mysterious creature sure that lived in
Hollywood unicorn you would now you can
see them playing a character you can see
the questions
I got Will Smith you know you don't talk
Instagram like making eggs
now with long-form podcast you could
never get away with that people that get
this phony they're not even a watch well
that's why a lot of actors don't see on
Long porn podcasts you can keep the act
up for so long like we don't have a lot
of actors on it no we've had one before
it's like hey man yeah give us some real
[ __ ] yeah yeah it's not that interesting
we went through a period where we had a
lot of actors and it just ended up being
with a Bookers [ __ ] foreign
guys who were that character you know
sure but if you're gonna do it come as
[ __ ] The Joker play the joke I want
you to be the Joker in your character
for an hour yeah if you're gonna do that
right shoot Calin in the face at the end
of the interview that's right that's
right shoot me in the face challenge
says one line just like it's the Joker
[Laughter]
but that's not to pigeonhole this but uh
that's why I called the special the last
late night this new hour I have is
because it was like an homage to the
dying art form that is the late night
talk that's why I loved your special
because it's different you know everyone
else is there's only so many ways you
can do a special I agree first time
where it was different and also had a uh
kind of a tribute to that like late
night like that Johnny Carson Vibe like
you're in a tuxedo yeah
oh man I was so good I was so into it I
know and he said you're so wrong and I
was like I know but it might be days
nobody wants to see this Dean Martin
[ __ ]
yeah well that's right that's when the
specialist called uh apes are not that
complicated
oh
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
no I loved it and I but I love that time
period like that's that's my thing I
wish I was the best alive back then I
love it but it's also like I think that
you know when you have the concept it's
like then you understand it's three
styles of writing right it's quick
one-liners monologue storytelling and
then traditional stand-up which any of
us could do right but then I don't think
people realize it's like oh you're a
comic just just go roast them your comic
go do crowd work it's like being a
comedian doesn't mean you're you can do
all those things they're all muscles and
so the the one-liner is I worked really
hard at that with Argus Hamilton he I
was like no look no further than Argus
Hamilton he's the [ __ ] best but
that's why the relatives was a throwback
like those one-liners like those
monologues yeah I loved it man to be
honest thank you I loved it he's great
man
because you can talk about all the old
school stories oh yeah the best oh and
who is who is uh who opened for Sinatra
forever um Tom Dreesen I I was on the
plane with Tom and what a great the
nicest what a great guy Tom Tom is still
getting up at the left funny yeah oh
still funny still killing it oh dude
handsome as it gets it's just it's a
throwback but crushing yeah whole host
he's a crushes he's a killer
unbelievable
to to be you know I don't know like when
I first passed at The Comedy Store The
Old Guard were all still there like all
mitzi's guys and who are those guys when
you were coming through Old Guard
like oh God I Argus has always been
there but Argus was the one that always
stayed relevant Argus kept writing he
was always keep with the times uh and
then other Comics they were still doing
like
Bush material and like Reagan stuff it's
like guys yeah what the it's 40 years
since then it's crazy like you would uh
anyways
I'm just
you're old hey man no I dude
last time I was at the concert I had to
follow a guy he did uh you always say
who it is I'll tell you off here
literally his Bill Clinton impression I
was like no hey bro yeah I've seen that
I know who you're talking about what are
you what are you doing oh man it didn't
go well I'm like yeah yeah
anything since that that was what 96
yeah yeah what the [ __ ] yeah but you I
loved it
this is fantastic
yeah I think the largest thing about
stand up is you've got to break your
patterns too you got to just it never
gets easy like it never gets easy I just
went through the worst writer's block I
just got out of it I had [ __ ]
writer's block for six months I I
couldn't [ __ ] right when you write
you say
have I done a penguin that's old [ __ ]
and I'm not doing that anymore I hold it
I hold I get in a horse stance sure I
get more stance I take a hemp rope and I
tie my my I tie my genitals to one leg
inside the root I tie the root down it
hurts really bad and it keeps creative
juices keeps me honest keeps me honest
and then I and I stay there until I come
up with a joke so it's not easy on my
legs my lower body is screaming but you
know what if it wants to keep stiff it
wants to stop screaming write a [ __ ]
joke discipline
right guys we're on a water board
himself I'll waterboard myself whatever
it tastes good that's right I pay I pay
guys I get a bunch of guys at Home Depot
I have them come over to the house I put
a cloth up in my head and everybody gets
a piss uh until I come up with a joke so
I really push myself I really really
push myself whatever it takes guys I'm
proud of you yeah yeah so that'll get
you that'll get you thinking and writing
real quick
yes yes
these jokes written by stranger P
at your age does your bladder weaken
though yes
it has nothing to do with your platter
it has to do with your prostate getting
bigger apparently oh I'm pushing it
hasn't happened to me yet but my dad
were on the golf course just pulls his
dick out starts pissing I go what are
you doing he goes pain the ass I'm off
so my prostates wow I love being outside
just I feel like a real rebel I feel
like a Hell's Angel yeah I love it I'm
just gonna piss right how old are you
dude 48. other [ __ ] Asians dude hey
[Laughter]
all right things have been tough you
look good 55. really Kellen you look
fantastic at first yeah honestly yeah
Daddy Daddy is uh daddy woke up with a
crazy boner this morning and I thought I
still got it he only sells that but in
the last three years you know man it's a
good that's a good last few years father
time went yeah
I'll give you a few more wrinkles on
forehead like like technology age starts
becoming exponential like you know the
next year you can't see your eyes are
[ __ ] up so right right I I've always
played uh ice hockey adult league and it
wasn't until this past season I was
skating in my life my legs just they
just stopped we're done we're done you
can't like you I I go 45 seconds on a
shift and then my legs just stop I know
I can't move that's because you you live
on Waffle House and you don't really
exercise I respect you decide to play
Ice Hockey once every two weeks and you
wonder why your legs are like I don't
I'm not used to kill this yeah yeah you
got to kind of okay yeah it's a daily
challenge
it's not the same it's the daily Brian
call me when you guys were in Nashville
doing the Pod and he's like you should
see Steve's diet I'm like I have to eat
and he tells me I'm like God I respect
him I eat like I thought I was gonna go
bad on them
Steve because you do the same thing at
12 30 at night I'm like this guy you and
you and Brandon
really not like that he'll go to
McDonald's
right there just went he'll eat the
whole thing at 12 at night I'd be like
oh my God I could never handle that oh
but you're you're I stay with you and
you'll throw a steak on at one in the
morning and a wheel of cheese and like
drinking one you think you're better
than us complain about like do my face
guys those days are over those days are
over
if I eat a steak and drink one glass of
wine at night now you wake up like a
sharp pain oh no I'll wake up at three
in the morning like oh what the [ __ ]
it's so hot I'm in the hair Sahara no no
my body
you can just eat and sleep
but you still you still work out quite a
bit yeah both of you guys too I haven't
lately I've been really sad and stressed
but yeah I hear you what is your go-to
your guilty pleasure what used to be uh
sweet ice cream was my number one
downfall but um I have real sensitive
teeth
um because I was using like that
[ __ ] like rope charcoal uh
toothpaste and it ruined my teeth oh
it's so sensitive it's woke but yeah no
I bought this I know I got it from Nancy
Pelosi no I did Nancy Pelosi's husband
sold me this toothpaste and there's it's
just like charcoal and I was like oh
this is supposed to be better for you
there's no fluoride Pelosi's husband
yeah I sold it he had toothpaste yeah
that's how he's like a multi-billionaire
that somebody sells underwear and
hammers
yeah
no but uh so I used that weird like
hippie toothpaste not the Republican
toothpaste no no that says fluoride
that's why everyone's teeth is so light
but uh no I use that toothpaste and then
yeah the Republican toothbrush do you
use it and you deny Alex yes
[Laughter]
whatever toothpaste DeSantis is using up
but no I uh it ruined my teeth yeah like
so sensitive so like it's actually a
blessing disguise joke's on you because
now I can't have sugar
ah nice teeth nice dry Satan Brandon's
teeth are such a Minefield like it's
gonna be so bad if he doesn't do
something and I mean what do you mean so
oh you Cheerio his tea is nice all
[ __ ] up his his enamel is all gone
it's gonna be pain bro the Pain's coming
okay you're Invisalign I got two more
weeks [ __ ] you 20 days
I got 23 days so sick you're Invisalign
if you didn't do it I don't think it's
tracking
oh no you don't think it's working I can
see from here no the bottom teeth still
look like a city skyline I can see it's
a problem yeah but then I'm gonna have
them whitened yeah I'm gonna have them
that makes them more sensitive manicured
but when do you get fitted for the
then you then you wear a retainer at
night you piece when you get that what
then you get these are real questions
piece of [ __ ] why why is it okay to be
you can't be racist you can't be well
transphobic but you can be age phobic
sorry age phobic how good you look I
just think you said [ __ ] Invisalign
just get
so Primal just no just get uh yeah right
remember that no just get um veneers
yeah you can do that when you park in a
handicapped spot though people like like
you get what when you get out they're
like yeah of course you need it I do
work I never Park in a handicap but I
park illegally all the time because I
roll the dice
I roll the dice and once in a while I
get a whopping I have a hard time worth
it no don't act like you're badass
about your Invisalign I know there's
nothing badass about that yeah I know I
know I know [ __ ] I've just never since
you were young you would eat like that
like is that where it comes from because
when I was a kid in my parents let's get
the calories
oh that's a good question 100 Ryan grew
up in like you know I don't know I grew
up I grew up around the wrist craps but
you know traveling like in Iraq what did
the chef prepare for me this morning he
did but for me my parents were like dude
whatever you're gonna eat we're gonna
you know start fast food all the time I
love fast food I love it I love in and
out I love Arby's I love Arby's so
underrated they're curly friend oh my
God the apple turnover oh come on now
God damn it dude hey hit the showers
guys what's up but Brian when you go to
the Golden Corral
from eight to ten
before you see the matinee
I don't like this podcast
filling soft foods
okay I love me I'm scared
your go-to's in and out Arby's I love in
and out I love pizza pizzas probably my
go-to I [ __ ] love you found good
pizza in Nashville
uh that's a tough one yeah that's a
tough one yeah yeah that's been tough
but the hot chicken I mean yeah they're
good that's my go-to yeah hey I the uh
taco place what's that place called
oh uh Mojo tacos that place it's got
something to say Brian by the way just
turn me up if you wanna
look that place has got keep talking I'm
gonna beat you up
I'm gonna come and beat you up
Steve Steve has road rage and picks
fights are you still doing that because
I don't want you to do that what are you
talking about anger management oh my God
you have to go to anger management but
the problem is he'll pick a fight and
then get his jaw broken I need you to
stop doing that with people hey man that
was years ago I know but you're a
hothead and I've seen you in the car
I've seen you [ __ ] yelling at people
Brian's a holiday to do though no not
not in the car
uh road rage I I don't do that because I
don't know if the guy's a gun right if
I'm gonna fight the only time I'm gonna
I'm gonna fight as if there was a guy
tailgating me with my children in the
car and I was gonna kill him I was gonna
kill him I waited I followed him to uh I
don't get into it did you have anything
again
no no and I was uh I was younger and uh
I was a younger I said to my girl at the
time I said I'm willing to take the jail
time right now no really no I was gonna
do something bad
and then I slew him no I didn't but I I
well then I shot him no it just didn't
work out because
I don't want to talk about
but let's talk about it
listen there was a time I was going to
kill you well he was tailgating my
children right his huge truck like this
far away from my my children
just pull over did you have sped up you
think huh could you just got out of the
way right no
a Ford Fiesta only goes so fast yes and
I was I was in a rickshaw
I was pulling it it's the new year
you're a new year you're on the road
this week right bud I am I'm on the road
I got I got it comedy club in San Diego
be fun buddy it's gonna be fun Thursday
Friday Saturday and I'm in Vegas Fort
Wayne Indiana you're in Vegas I'm in
Vegas Wise Guys this Thursday Friday
Saturday Sin City tiger thing will be
available at all shows but it sells out
fast so make sure you get your tickets
early to grab that bottle of tiger thick
so that's Vegas this Thursday Friday
Saturday Brian's in San Diego come get
you some mic drop comedy club and then I
got Fort Wayne Indiana after that now
look it's the New Year okay on it's got
something cool it's got the New Year all
you a hub for everything you need to
start the year right but are they doing
big discounts throughout January you get
20 off select supplements and nutrition
10 off select Fitness and 50 off digital
eye streaming Fitness yes they go to the
gym anymore that's the is that also
means Alpha Brain uh is there for you
guys as well to support that Focus huge
discount for training you can do at your
crib join the New Year all you on at six
challenge a six week workout and
lifestyle program with over 36 000 in
prize money up for grabs the challenge
helps you connect with others in the
audit community so you can support each
other and achieve your goals for more
information to unlock your savings go to
audit.com slash
f-a-t-k all right again that's audit.com
f-a-t-k you get 20 off supplements
tempus off select Fitness items 50 off
digital items and you know you get that
deal on Alpha Brain that's on it.com
slash f-a-t-k you're welcome now let's
get back
but you know you don't seem like an
angry guy no I'm not by Nature an angry
person but by any means no but uh
but I I look I I think it's like the
rare occasion that
you know you get poked it's like you
know it's like zero to sixty but it's it
takes so much you're a very fair-minded
traditional guy very courteous when yeah
and respectful and I think when somebody
is
he's a very traditional uh he's a
traditionalist and and very very
cognizant of people's feelings always
gives people the benefit of the doubt
but when people are dicks or they're
rude usually you'll usually you step no
you go hard that's fine you don't do
anything until
until I think they kind of
force the issue and then then you see
red you're currently anger yeah then you
become Bruce Wayne yeah yes but not as
rich
so like Steve that because Steve isn't
going to train in Jiu Jitsu boxing but
he will fight you right now
it's like he will fight you right now
getting [ __ ] up well the my my I think
I talked about but the best fight I ever
I was ever in was the black guy in the
elevator and I pulled the shirt over his
head Hockey style yeah and I was like oh
he definitely does know hockey
well you were with a racist girl right
oh yeah oh yeah she dropped the end bomb
yeah yeah that's a girl white girl yeah
yeah were you like were you just
standing
who the hell does that yeah we're in a
Sears elevator who does that when you
look at somebody you're a giant [ __ ]
who does that yeah are we in 1950 you
[ __ ] like I'd be like but wait why
did she what it was just out of the blue
so I think I I don't know if I I told
the story on the but but basically I was
with Sebastian we met some girls after
the show this is years ago we're both
single back then uh we all hook up I say
I'm gonna walk the girls to their car
the girl's in the elevator and in the
lobby there's a guy holding the door
open
and he's with four or five other guys so
you know he's black guy and so it's it's
obviously pertinent of the story so so
basically he's talking or talking or
talking or trying to get her number
trying to get her she's like I'm not
giving my number I slip under his arm
I'm like all right guys you know I told
him yeah but have a good night yeah
let's let's wrap this up uh he's not I
don't I'm Patrick Swayze in Ghost I'm
I'm not there I'm a specter so he keeps
talking to her come on girl come on give
me your number give me she's like I'm
not giving you my number you and then
she dropped it Jesus he walked into the
elevator the door's shut he goes towards
her and I'm like oh [ __ ] now I gotta so
we both grab each other
and it's one of those things it's an
elevator like this make or break right
shark goes over the head pop pop pop
goes down chill dog chill chill dog
chill that's what I hear I know
chill dog Chill by the way it's all what
we knocked the elevator off its Moorings
or something so now we're stuck
I'm hitting him
Sarah Smiles by Hall and Oates is
playing so anytime I hear that song I
have like PTSD anytime in a Walgreens or
CBS so I'm sorry so then he gets back up
and he pulls his shirt over and I'm like
brace myself against the wall Mike the
girl's crying I'm like he's gonna come
at me again and he's staring at me he's
looking at me he's like
and I go oh here he comes and he goes
we're going BT's Comic View I'm like
yes I was he's like you did the Bruce
Lee I'm like [ __ ] yeah hell yeah dude
and uh then we started talking and he
was super cool
I didn't remember that part of the story
and then you guys beat up the girl
then we Eiffel towered her
um but then then we hear the elevator
and we go back to the lobby as soon as
the doors open his boys rush in pop pop
shirt ripped I'm bleeding here I'm
bleeding here he goes no no guys guys
he's a comic if you remember Bruce Lee
they go oh [ __ ]
and then they all take off the lobby guy
the hotel guy says I just called the
cops the girl is crying I want nothing
to do with this [ __ ] girl yeah and
I'm standing in the lobby bleeding shirt
ripped Sebastian Maniscalco comes out of
the business center and he's just
holding a cappuccino goes what the [ __ ]
happened to you guy
literally two minutes the whole thing
happened like it was crazy the [ __ ]
happened to you
aren't you embarrassed oh for sure yeah
oh my God he he's a great story he's the
best I got in a fight I was in a [ __ ]
elevator with these Russians and they
said you are you must we must break you
and I said guys and I dropped I said not
in eight flights well I dropped a smoke
bomb and uh here we go yep yep there we
go fantasy time oh I don't see nothing I
don't see enough
yeah because the smoke Rises and then I
go low yeah and I and I go with my
little a little bit
yeah I just what is up there uh oh it's
a Spanish for Stiletto and I and I and I
cut their uh Achilles and I go I'm not
gonna do sports for a while guys yeah
they all fall to the ground then I just
walked out wow so that's my story what
was the last fight you've been in Brian
um
I don't know a long time ago yeah yeah I
don't I will avoid 20s who fights
especially with cell phones out there I
don't oh my God can you imagine that's
why I know it's a current event that's
why like with the Dana White Stuff it's
like bro you know everyone has you're so
famous yeah you know everyone has cell
phones yeah yeah it's just it's you and
Dana you know he's not he's a smart dude
Dana's a very smart guy like you know
when you walk in yo have you not seen
this no I haven't seen this oh okay so
that's his wife they've been together 26
years oh no so he said some of his wife
I think he said I'm gonna pay Francis
and she went oh I'm a Brandon
slapped her
see that kick is where it gets spicy
right Jesus Christ so this is all over
that's that's a husband wife [ __ ] that I
you know apparently they they were like
we're fine we were both drunk we
apologized our kids moving on so
an hour later they're banging yeah I
mean we took it up with our kids that's
right yeah
listen I'll joke I made a joke about it
but I said all jokes aside I like I like
the way he handled me like Kate my wife
and I were drunk we addressed it with
the kids please this is a private matter
yeah I should have never hit a girl and
it's like all right I get it the only
this is my thing with this and I don't
want him to lose his job I don't think
you should take a leave of absence from
the UFC
but can you name any other person sports
or if this was caught on tape say say
Jerry Jones for the Dallas Cowboys it
was caught doing this name another
person in a major sports League who
could have this evidence wife or not and
would still have a job well I would say
that he's been married for I don't know
how long they've made this marriage work
for this long they had a tiff it was
public they both said we're we're this
we love each other we we're we're a
family [ __ ] off we're moving on I think
most of us all of us go that's a
marriage that's been working for a long
time I'm not you know for me out of
respect yeah it's like you guys handle
your business and it's too bad we caught
it on tape but it's like I'm not going
to say anything I think if she came out
she said yeah she's never done this
before which I don't believe but you
know well I mean I don't know what to
believe I mean I think well first of all
she hit public setting she hit him first
so my guess doesn't make you okay my
guess is it's a physical sometimes in
that relationship and there are
relationships like this it gets physical
and women can be very physical with men
too they get angry they express
themselves that way it's a problem the
guy reacts this is this is what happens
in many marriages in many relationships
and that should in fact I agree with you
but I'm just with that I'm just saying
that that kind of stuff will happen but
it feels like they've been married for
when you've been married that way yeah
you got kids 26 years I've known each
other since they're 12. okay that's a
long time I'm not about to say
[ __ ] all I'm gonna let them handle their
business it sounds like she's yeah she's
there he's there and they they know what
I'm not saying that I'm saying again I
don't justify a man-handed a woman in
any circumstance whether they hit first
or not my my question is name another
figure popular figure in sports yeah
where that video could be shown and they
have a job go I would say this
Mayweather say when you watch no I would
say no no I would say this there's
there's no video though
let me ask you this so when you watch
that who is that running back from the
Falcons hit his girlfriend in that's
what he loses I'm sorry uh uh uh right
oh my god when I saw him on Baltimore
yeah when I saw him hit that woman like
that yeah I went there is I don't give a
[ __ ] what you say I don't care if you've
known that person for 12. there's no
excuse you you with that kind of power
you swung your arm and tried to [ __ ]
take her head off yeah end of story
sorry yeah sure yeah yeah that was Danny
got hit he had and it was this bang bang
they both tapped each other here and
then it got into a scuffle well he
pushed her down but I think it's a
scuffle we all like all of us go uh
that's not whack or punch there are
degrees to this [ __ ] it was refreshie
there are degrees there's a wake-up call
she hit him first you know it was a
reaction they're drunk we've all seen
this in Bars by the way everybody's seen
that [ __ ] in bars I'll tell you right
now
that happens in a bar you should come to
uh you should come to New York that guy
is getting pounded by eight dudes yeah
100 at least in my crew for sure
absolutely he's not making another yeah
yeah I I but again my question you gave
the Ray Rice yeah it's not surprising is
what I'm saying that he get he got a he
essentially got a pass because he and
his wife came together and said we're a
family we talk to our kids or we don't
know if he got a pass oh okay this is
new
this is this week what are they gonna do
I think to his benefit is that Buffalo
Bill you watch football that Buffalo
Bills players you know he basically died
on the field that resuscitate him after
six minutes we never had something like
that happen they canceled the game
that's in the news cycle
so this this got buried you know and
Daniel should be thinking his lucky
stars now the MMA community in the world
I'm in obviously it's big news but the
news cycle is all about the bill safety
uh Hamlet it's all about that
I actually did it's a private issue I
don't think you should ever hit a woman
there should be some disciplinary action
taken whether it's he misses two papers
I don't know what they're gonna do but
he's also kind of like a renegade right
he he
he doesn't play by the rules I think
there's also that kind of I I think like
I don't know how he handled everything
during kovid he went off the grid he
kind of came out against a lot of things
I think I I think he has this kind of
like Persona where I'm not saying it it
negates it or it lets it be acceptable
but I I don't want to answer your
question if two guys
if a guy hit a guy and a guy hit hit the
guy back right or none of us would be
having a conversation right we'd be like
oh [ __ ] you gotta hit of course okay
yeah now this is a man and a woman right
right and the woman hit him first yes
married you take it though yes I
understand dude yeah I've I've taken
that yeah yeah okay we all have but what
I'm trying to say is that in this world
of equal rights we should also be
talking about her who initiated that if
we're going to talk about Dana let's
talk about his wife too no that's a good
point no no because it's the it's not
okay for women it is the point because
we are living in a time when if you're
going to make a distinction between men
and women be careful yeah because it's
very interesting how you have to do you
you can make it over here but not over
here now let's be consistent across the
board yeah and we're not now I get why
we're not personally I I understand sure
there's a big difference between a woman
hitting a man and a man hitting a man
there's a big [ __ ] difference
personally I that's why I also don't
think biological males should be in
female sports personally Dana's probably
230 pounds well that's on on steroids to
your points yeah to your point to my
point you know like I I I
agree with that but if we're going to
talk about the narrative out there let's
talk about both of them sure that's
important anyway we've I'd love to know
what he said though no it's good to talk
about me yeah what do you mean this is
the [ __ ] new cycle yeah we need you
I've never heard of that and that
happened New Year's Day right or New
Year's Eve
um
in Mexico Cabo San Lucas that's best
punch I've ever seen thrown in a bar was
a woman on a man and [ __ ] girlfriend
boyfriend St Patty's Day at Peter
McManus I think it's on 17th Street in
New York City right in Manhattan and I I
when I you're gonna think I'm kidding I
saw 17 fights and and I remember it was
17 because it was on 17th Street right I
remember and I remember uh I don't know
if that bar is still there but um
[ __ ] uh
uh the woman just the guy gets in there
they're talking and he gets in her face
and she just went she went it was so
perfect biggest [ __ ] clearing a softball
player and just turned crack and his
head went
he was huge too his head went this way
and he grabbed her and they went into it
and the bartender was so bored with it
he was like this he goes guys come on
back this Dana thing what I find
interesting again I you know I don't
want to lose his job in any facet
there's going to be some discipline
because you're talking about WME and
um ESPN Mickey Mouse who you know Mickey
Mouse you know they don't play any games
so they'll get to it I'm just curious
what they're gonna do but he's made a
lot of enemies
and so this is this is going to be
they'll get to it yes once this NFL news
cycle to get to it you know hopefully I
I pray the guy he didn't lose his job
um you ever been hit by one yes but hold
on my thing is is I want you to realize
how powerful Dana White is I think
everyone needs to acknowledge this
ESPN now ESPN right now is running a
story on the head coach of the US men's
soccer team that there was uh an
altercation with his wife ready 30 years
ago where he kicked her in the legs
they're covering that but didn't cover
what happened on New Year's Eve with
Dana White who is one of the faces of
ESPN I want you to realize how far his
net is casted it might be a little bit
different Bob because there's a big
difference if your wife comes forward
and says 30 years ago he beat the [ __ ]
out of me or kicked me in the legs if
that's the case that's very different
because what happens is now in social
media the the the the victim of uh
domestic crime whatever it is has the
story and you get a statement so just
know that there is a difference in this
case his wife and he together came
forward right this happened last
Saturday another one happened 30 years
ago and it was uh you got to know the
fact of that story it happened 30 years
ago and they were trying to they were
trying to Blackmail the coach and he
came out and was like hold on 30 years
ago yes I kicked my wife in the leg
my point is is that is currently a
running story on ESPN Not Dana White
which last Saturday
slapped and threw his wife down to the
ground and kicked her is that not
strange to anybody in this room
Fox isn't covering it right ESPN's not
covering it I never heard of it until
today
I would say Dana is one of the most
famous men on the planet I'm just saying
that's how powerful he is
which is impressive it's impressive to
be honest it's impressive
he's the face of the sport he's the most
famous guy yeah he's more famous than
any fighter he just yeah remember
Fighters come and go yeah there's one
constant the the two most famous people
in the UFC are not fighting it's Joe
Rogan and Dana White right the guys who
don't fight
I don't think it's a problem because it
makes sense one owns it and he's very
outlandish and he's the reason why the
sports are where it's at and then also
for Joe Rogan he's the best sports
combat commentary of all time and he
honestly has the biggest platform in the
world so he's not Fear Factor so it
makes sense I don't think it's it's not
their fault they're more offense than
the fighters just what it is
but the point is the guy who is the face
of the organization has this recent
video who's trying to [ __ ] blackmail
this coach what was that about you do
you have that story he's 18 years old
what's the coaches I didn't say it was
18. that's what he said oh you found it
yeah yeah they're trying but so I think
he came out to get in front of it yeah
this is what happens people will use
whatever they can to block him he may
kick in his then girlfriend future wife
in 1991 when he was 18. give me a
[ __ ] it's crazy I'm sharing this
story after 31 years because it's
important to understand it was an event
that shaped me but doesn't Define me as
a single isolated event over three
decades ago and terrible decision made
in a bad moment by an 18 year old wow as
a team we emphasize accountability
honesty and growth those are just
principles we still instill with this
team so I live my life I I'm surprised
that's even a story because he was being
blackmailed and they knew they knew
right there that any story no matter how
old will [ __ ] ruin you not true
100 true
it's 100 True Dana no but for the most
part absolutely yeah you know but he's
also extremely media Savvy I mean if
anybody knows the most the most yeah I
think you don't want to fight with that
guy
I I think he would know how to you know
handle the Optics of this he I don't
think he he meets the bull halfway man
that guy [ __ ] yeah he'll be right
there right there on your face right
there on your face I mean I I don't know
we're giving him too much credit I think
he calls because he has heavy influence
with Fox used to work at Fox having
influence with ESPN I can tell you a
story to blow your dick off about ESPN
and Disney going at Dana he calls him he
goes hey here's what's going on right
we're not covering this right you got it
right it is being covered
not by ESPN Fox but it is everywhere he
was on by the way to your point he's on
TMZ but TMZ handled it in such a way
that it's like they made a deal how to
how to make the story come out and Dana
was on at TMZ and they were kind of like
cool to each other it's a little weird
I'm just saying this is my uh up to and
I'm glad he's okay
name one other person in professional
sports that could get away with this
I would love to hear it Steve yeah you
know Sports why do you have a Pittsburgh
Steeler hat on
because I like the Steelers yeah I'm
from Pittsburgh yeah like that that's
all you have to say yeah okay just
curious
from Pittsburgh bro yeah that makes
sense yeah yeah take it easy yeah
they're good what happened nothing yeah
what's up okay you're a sports fan yeah
okay I'm sure you're a legit one you
know there's guys coming here yeah like
oh you're stainless you know Cardinals
Fan Steve give me somebody what do you
think what's going on with Tamar Hamlin
here they said there's signs of
improvement that's the last thing I
heard is he breathing on his own
this gets dicey and I want to give my
real opinion on it but I know I know
what you're going to see it gets in the
weeds I know what you're gonna say oh
I'm gonna I'm not gonna mention anything
about that stuff what I'm gonna say is
it's okay for the public to ask
questions of all these young athletes
having heart issues because they because
of myocarditis
whatever you want whatever I don't give
I don't give a [ __ ] what it is whether
they're doing fast food whatever it is
it's okay to go hold on why are some of
these young professional athletes
falling over having heart issues now
what's going on here then people go oh
you're just anti-vid no no whoa no no
I'm literally just asking the question
I'm not it's not a left or right thing
I'm just I'm just curious why these
young athletes all of a sudden are
having these issues that's it
but in that moment right it was it was
the shock right the trauma of of
literally it wasn't a bad hit he did the
hitting he said way worse hits man I've
seen way worse but the the the the
helmet his helmet drove right that's
what they're saying correct and that did
I guess it's having a WWF guys before
where they get slammed and they fall on
their chest right and that you just want
to make sure he didn't get any brain
damage from a lack of oxygen going to
his brain well they said he is gonna
have lung lung damage he is and then
there's this gentleman I forget he's
gonna he's on a uh Cleveland sports show
he broke it down he's like here's the
real issue so he he was I think his uh
he was a second round draft pick I think
you know sixth round I think was it six
but either way so he his contract he's
like uh it's right over a million
dollars with the 850 000 uh bonus and
then he contracted like 120 whatever
and he's saying how this kid's not set
and in order to get compensation so you
get money after you retire you have to
play four years basically have to play
four years and he went he broke down
everything that the NFL pays out like
with the CT rule that you know around
that huge issue yeah they've only paid
66 of the former athletes only six
percent of all those athletes in
football who have CT Real CT they only
paid six percent of what they're
supposed to pay but then the Optics are
does the NFL the NFL's got to cover
these expenses but then you open
Pandora's box right it's like well you
[ __ ] did that it's gonna be to your
point you know how many thousands of
guys that are former former employees
that are like what the [ __ ] I you know
I'm sitting here I've been filling out
the paperwork I'm reaching out to you
guys there's been no support whatsoever
so I think uh to your point it'll be
interesting to see what the NFL they
have to cover it of course well here's
my thing book cover is expenses but what
about like he's screwed like you know
let's say he's made I don't know 1.5
million after taxes you're screwed and
you dedicate your life to professional
football and then this horrible incident
happened like you're [ __ ] and then
with Social Security like guys they
can't walk or whatever they have issues
50 15 the less than 15 of the NFL who
apply for Social Security got it less
than 15 of that 15 Social Security
Social Security they can't walk but you
have to wait Social Security or Medicaid
no social security after you're 55 from
from and so you need the government to
go yep you're disabled but right now the
NFL now they walk us through that
because
but the NFL goes hold on the government
doesn't know what they're doing even
though they're experts when it comes to
disability we have our own in-house team
who's gonna make sure you're disabled
even though the government goes Yep this
guy's over 55 can't walk can't talk
whatever you guys should be paying them
that phone goes no we'll take it from
here they have their own board that you
have to see and they approve less than
15 and then it used to be fifty four
hundred dollars a month they would pay
they've lowered that to three thousand
you mean the very League that denied
that CTE existed these guys are
interested okay good luck with that yeah
no no that's crazy
so this poor hamling guy it's like oh
dude even if he comes out of this you
don't think he'll play again
we don't know I don't know how bad it is
you know from that six minutes of CPR
you know those ribs are broken you know
and there's lungs down she's not playing
this year
Jesus heavy [ __ ] [ __ ] dude that was
surreal to watch though
but even when the ESPN it's like just
cut away we don't what do we oh I was
like why is it taking so long to cancel
this stop what is happening yeah and the
NFL came out was like we because I think
they were worried he was going to die
they were waiting to see what the [ __ ]
was really going on right no because
they put him in an ambulance then got
him out of there yeah but they waited a
certain amount of time so his mom could
come from the stadium down to the
ambulance yeah which is I don't know
what's going on there but then the rumor
came out on social media like the NFL
officials told the teams both head
coaches and the players hey you have
five minutes to warm up then we're back
to business and the coaches and the team
were like [ __ ] you we're not playing no
there's no way we can play but the NFL
was like no we never said that it's like
I don't know yeah yeah I don't know how
you play I mean that that you're just
[ __ ] you're [ __ ] well you saw
everybody on the sideline I mean like
absolutely stunned shock
yeah never
I hope I hope you don't see it again oh
people come Skip Bayless right Skip
Bayless yeah this is you're getting
canceled people come from this dude so
he put no no doubt the NFL is
considering postponing the rest of this
game but how this late in the season a
game of this magnitude is crucial to the
regular season outcome which suddenly
seems so irrelevant
dude
that's what he does not irrelevant so
what but watch this so the next so he'd
post that people are so mad at skip
right they've been trying to cancel them
forever right next to you post that so
what is that what night is that is that
what was that Monday Night Football was
it so Tuesday him and Shannon sharp do
undispute they've had issues before oh
yeah watch this I watch this let's go
Jim thank you
I said over under Shannon Park's ways
with Skip Bayless oh under three months
any takers I don't know we've had issues
before though because skip started
making fun of kind of Shannon's career
compared to Tom Heidi no and Shannon was
like what the [ __ ] and people like oh
this is all just you know it's fake
they're doing this for them because I'm
like I don't think so it's clearly an
issue there that's what he gets paid to
be he's there to start fires that's Skip
Bayless the same thing with uh God who's
the other guy Stephen A Smith I mean
they're throwing bombs all the time
they're there to be controversial and so
Skip Bayless you're all thinking oh this
is uncomfortable for him it's another
day at the office I'm sure yeah is it he
said way worse I think so yeah that was
even that bad of a table it was just bad
timing didn't he get in trouble for for
tweeting skip you're the man and stuff
but it was oh no he had a burner account
yeah someone was like uh
get his own birthday Camp it was like
skip I think you're the only thing great
on Fox or whatever and then but it was
from his account and so I was like hey
Skip you forgot to use your burn account
you're the man skip like oh God that is
so funny
um I I don't know what do you think of
his tweet I I I I he's definitely done
worse stuff but he did say in it to
Steve's point it's like it's kind of his
gig dude you know it's like well I
thought I watched that Chen I watched
him comparing him Tom Brady which I
thought was obnoxious as [ __ ] because
Shannon sharp is a Hall of Famer I'm
from Denver he's on the Ring Of Fame the
guy thank you the guy as far as Leaders
go yeah one of the greatest of all Skip
Bayless I know is a pro athlete and one
of the greatest football players of all
time and also he's the Jim Thorpe of
[ __ ] commentary yeah but like skip
you don't know what though like that's
that was so obnoxious to me like I
watched that and I was like God you're
such a dick like I I don't know what
you're trying to do maybe maybe it's a
way to get ratings and we're all talking
about it but but so that tweet itself
feels like he said he said how do you
cancel the game this late in the season
yeah but it all does seem so irrelevant
so I thought that was uh
way worse than this I think it's the
accumulation of everything he's done
because he's a huge LeBron hater so I
think so you know obviously again to
Steve's Point that's his job yeah so
it's like CNA Smith's such a big Dallas
Cowboys hater so once they see a little
[ __ ] in the armor that Onslaught comes
man yeah so with the hammer and stuff
like now's our time it's like man he's
done Weight yeah that that but that
tweet he did say you know how do you
cancel a game this late in the season
um but that all seems so right
um this late season the game of this Max
was crucial in regular season outcome
which suddenly seems so irrelevant
meaning he is putting Hamlin above what
were those tweets after that because
yeah I tried to become respectful wasn't
that respectful I didn't think it was
that bad now I don't know now you gotta
realize this too but in this day and age
of victimhood this is an opportunity to
go what the [ __ ] get him yeah exactly
but but here's the other thing is
um you know why Shannon Sharps on the
show uh no let's get biggest single
Handler's like this is the guy okay this
is like he handpicked him obviously it's
a cherry
chair right like that this is I mean one
of the toughest kids to get in sports
because you remember he left ESPN when
Stephen A Smith came over here and then
hand-picked Shannon sharp to give him
this huge platform yeah so it's it's and
here he goes nothing is more important
this young man's health that is the
point of my last tweet I'm sorry if it
was misunderstood but his health is all
that matters I mean and he's there you
go that's cool I mean I I accept that
from Skip Bayless
I mean I don't you know what I'm saying
I mean he explained his tweet I think he
was saying that I think Shannon wanted
him to take it down
and he's like I'm you know he's standing
yeah I don't know [ __ ]
what he said no I mean I think I
understand why he doesn't want to take
it down because I I don't think it's
that bad I actually it's not that bad
yeah also we know how it goes when you
apologize for things it doesn't get you
out of the water no they go oh we can
get him to apologize yeah and then
especially when you're making hot takes
all the time dude
man Shannon Shannon's an emotional guy
too but I I think he was just still
pissed about that [ __ ] Brady thing I
think he's pissed about all of it
because you gotta remember it's like
again and I'm nothing compared to
Shannon sharp he's the Hall of Famer I I
won't be in the Hall of Fame in the UFC
but it'd be like you
you know doubling down on something
being super in insensitive to some like
UFC situation and then talking [ __ ] to
me on here I'm like the [ __ ] are you
right it's an ad hominem like it's like
a personal attack you wrestled in high
school yeah yeah hold on but I rest I do
a little wrestling now no uh you know
but you don't say but like Skip Bayless
was even a good high school that's
basketball player right well that's
right his brothers won the greatest
all-time he's one of the greatest
all-time dude he was such a leader so he
was the captain the Denver Broncos when
they won the Super Two Super Bowls he
went to Baltimore won Super Bowl Ray
Lewis was on that team Ed Reed was on
that team Jonathan Ogden was on that
team Jamal Jamal Anderson yeah dude he
was the leader on that team that's out
of that think about that's how alpha he
is it's like when I showed up today
no you guys get it I do I was like
you're the Shannon sharp of this [ __ ]
thank you and you're Skip Bayless what I
mean with your background why do I have
to be Skip Bayless you have the same
athletic career
same hot takes
not really I wish you did
I wish you did I can't make a fist
but I think skips is an accumulation of
just all that [ __ ] talking then
obviously if you're a LeBron fan
whatever Chan fan Now's the Time you
draw the breaks the camel's back yeah
that's it but I don't think it's gonna
break their back Fox is pretty you know
that's they paid him so much money but
this is this it we're talking about them
right now this is this is what they want
at the end of the day it's what he looks
that clip got 6.4 million views yeah
kind of a lot
what else you got you
it's hot take
the Logan Paul
scam concerns people thought that he was
actually scamming using something called
crypto Zoo there's a guy what uh
that made this whole thing about it yeah
uh so Logan Paul responded to that you
made a seven minute video I didn't watch
it but he goes in he said you still
published a defamatory hit piece fully
knowing that I was innocent Josie could
enrich yourself in your 10 million
dollar Studio sharp 10 million dollar
Studio what kind of studio is this uh
but uh deeply on an ethical dangerously
misleading and illegal Paul says in
seven minute long response video
published on Tuesday any ads here I
suggest you use the money you got from
pumping your patreon to hire a good
lawyer you're gonna need it interesting
whoa yeah if Logan's actually innocent
of this stuff you know he was had a
didn't know what was going on you you
should go after that well um my
understanding is he bought they bought a
bunch of tokens I just this is my
understanding I might go wrong they
bought a bunch of they created a bunch
of tokens they bought them
and then the it was based on a game
that kids could play
and then they started talking about this
token that allows you to play this game
the problem was there was no game or the
game didn't work I'm I don't think it's
a game I'd rather you break down [ __ ]
football and then talk about Tampa two
zone defense in crypto yeah
really fun game that earns you money
yeah but so he's saying it's game but
it's not like I think he's being accused
of a pump and dump this crypto uh crypto
zoo is like he designed it to be a game
like that's why he's in crypto and yeah
and the coin you get an egg and you
hatch an egg into an animal and then you
can breed those animals to make more
animals
yeah
okay but what I'm saying is that is he
selling game boys wait wait he's selling
but if you're selling the eggs that you
previously own you you you create some
of the engineers these eggs now you and
your team
own already thousands of them thousands
of eggs on the open market though then
four months later you go to the you go
to the public and say by the way these
eggs are awesome
buy these eggs the price goes up and
then you can sell your eggs that would
be I think what he's being investigated
for or is that that's what the
accusation is that's not the case and
this guy's kind of exaggerating what
exactly is because crypto King is the
one who's kind of talking about this his
partner in this was the the coffee Zilla
was getting all his information from
crypto King right who has an agenda
against Logan yeah and who also made a
lot of money himself correct so crypto
King apparently bought the idea was that
according to Coffee Zilla crypto King
bought a lot of these they a bunch of
these got bought and they didn't know
where they were and it turned out it was
crypto King who bought them yeah right
is that am I right so far and Logan and
one other person are the only ones that
haven't sold any of these coins and that
guy sold his before they were also
cashed out already so that guy's the one
who made the money but Logan never sold
his he never sold them yeah I thought he
made 40 million dollars or some [ __ ] not
off that um
okay Logan said he lost money so far
into making this crypto
thing
okay feel old yes dude I'm glad to hear
that [ __ ] because I like Logan Paul but
I love them I was worried that it was
going to come out as this terrible thing
but
again people listen you know a lot of
people don't like Logan Paul so now this
is the thing get you know he did the
dead body in the Japanese Japan Forest
it's another mistake get um this guy's
the worst yeah yeah any opportunity then
yeah come on man
but so Savvy incredibly intelligent
understands the landscape yeah brilliant
hard worker
what else you got you all right this is
sad news we actually brought up this
video not too long ago you know who Ken
Block is that really hell yeah he's a
super famous driver yeah dude yeah do a
best Hub with him he passed away yeah
Superman the second snowmobile snow
plower accident with you know pretty
high levels level people
so yeah I guess he was snowballing and a
snow snowmobile and then it went up oh
somehow and then upended and then it
fell on top of him oh yeah and he
survived so much like he is yeah he's a
wild dude he's drifting [ __ ] in Vegas we
watched it yeah so published Public
Safety announcement my buddy is the runs
the catastrophic injury Institute at
West Virginia hospital and every time
you see a spinal cord injury literally
I'm going down the hall people will
never walk again ever walk again ever
walk again people are brain dead ATVs
doing exactly that kids going too fast
snowmobiles ATVs all that [ __ ] going in
the air and it comes down on you that's
so heavy and dude and and it breaks
people's necks backs all the [ __ ]
time he literally was like I couldn't
believe it I was like how are they
making these things how are these things
legal go put a cage around them which
they do now
wow well I I just seen this uh
this documentary it came out years ago
the the crash reel about
um oh God I forget the guy's name uh
really talented snowboarder it was Sean
White's competitor for many years and
um they were talking that there you know
when it comes to like X Games and all
that stuff they're not like regulating
and saying guys this is too high now
yeah like we've got to stop doing this
and because the escalation keeps going
and going and going and going further
and further uh
there it is yeah that's it Kevin Pierce
Okay Kevin first fantastic documentary
but it's he obviously he got he got
waxed on a on a half pipe and the guy he
died no he he
was
generally like banged up and thinking
you're not gonna walk again uh and his
just life was changed after it and it
was it just documents his recovery yeah
and he's functioning now uh he his
memory is foggy there's a lot of issues
that uh obviously
brain trauma was he doing like the big
ear and just crashed well they keep
pushing it they keep pushing it they
keep pushing it so that you yeah at this
point there's no regulations yeah that's
that's the X Games right I'm gonna flip
my motorcycle what yeah I'm gonna flip
it twice excuse me have you seen like
just watch the videos of what they do on
mountain bikes now when they when when
they they're just on a mountain on a
cravat and they're doing [ __ ] when they
have the camera oh yeah on the trails
like this big so insane yeah it's well
you did some mountain biking for a while
right I mean I was still mountain biking
high level guys they're crazy I go on
Trails dude it's the craziest [ __ ] I've
ever seen in my life
it's so stupid I don't like Topanga
Canyon have you ever seen that it's so
interesting yeah oh POV with the GoPro
on there yeah yeah and literally they
fall it's game over it's game over like
those sheep that climb the mountain but
they're on bikes they're also like
that's a click where are you going oh
it's a clip but I'm gonna jump I'm gonna
land over there just barely it's insane
the anxiety from just watching a GoPro
[ __ ] you it's not for me it's like that
hardcore I don't like when they jump
between buildings and if you fall well
you fall for a long time [ __ ] you in the
squirrel suits I don't [ __ ] with any of
that I don't know I'm not interested it
makes me too nervous here's a what's
against no accident uh Jeremy Renner
just update oh Jesus he said he's really
banged up but he was able to have this
post here where he showed his face he
doesn't look his face isn't like crazy
crazy bad but his body it's not good no
it's not random apparently at least have
like major surgery yeah right he got his
body and his legs yeah
it's like a 14 000 pound snowmobile uh
snow plower he was helping like a
pedestrian who was like stuck he started
moving on his own so he tried to climb
back in and I guess he probably slipped
and it ran over Jesus Christ
[ __ ] my God but he's like a uh he's
like a real kind of guy's guy right he
fixes up homes he's yes yeah he's also
got some crazy high IQ like I think they
said something like so you're I mean
you're smarter than pretty much almost
everybody and he goes I think so yeah
he's got this crazy genius IQ like yeah
a poor guy though man now at least thank
God he's okay Wind River was so good man
God it's such a good movie all right so
Taylor
UFC Strike Force guy oh God yeah so he's
arrested in Mexico three coming in hot
for allegedly murdering his girlfriend
he even ex he explains it as what they
she admitted to him like she was banging
some other dude so so yeah so they're in
Mexico right you live in Mexico he had
this his girlfriend she admitted that
she's being some other dude
apparently he beat her so bad he killed
her but when the cops got there
he was like yeah we got an argument she
told me she cheated on me and I told her
go take a shower you filthy animal or
whatever because you're dirty she
slipped in the shower and the cop's like
right but then why is your entire body
covered in bruises and beaten oh my God
so he's [ __ ]
so this says mixing Outlet report to
that brownie alleged killed this uh his
girlfriend inside their hotel room
um the report says that brownie was
under the influence of alcohol and drugs
when the police arrived on the scene the
officer saw the woman lying naked on the
bed covered with a bed sheet however the
remarks of beatings and bruised on her
face and she's pronounced dead on the
scene Baroni allegi told police it was
around 3 P.M when he started to smoke
marijuana and drink a beer in his room
when the two got into argument doing the
argument broney's girlfriend probably
told him that she was having sex with
another dude after that the former UFC
fighter threw his girlfriend to the
shower she hit her head on the ground
as Phil Brown's girlfriend was trying to
get up uh Phil Brown did help her up and
then put her on the bed and he proceeded
to remove her clothes put a bet you on
top of her according to the report
broney's girlfriend then asked for a
cigarette and a bear so he left the room
to get it by the time he returned he
knows his girlfriend was dead
um reports state that Brony is arrested
for murder
this is a really depressing yes it is
episode guys
usually we have lots
like but did she get him first yeah
oh my God oh my God I gotta watch like a
Pixar film they're like
don't watch Toy Story 4 it's depressing
I'll cry yeah I don't know I never I
don't know I never watched him fight I
don't know he's old school oh man oh
[ __ ] so much fun this [ __ ] would just
stand and Bang Yeah Speedos you would
have loved him his body jacked yeah well
juicy as hell I don't love him too much
now enjoy that Mexican prison yeah 170
or something
uh yeah 170. Jesus enjoy that makes you
in prison yeah
well I don't know yep you guys see the
Indiana Jones trailer oh is there a new
one but they're doing there's a new one
see that's your Guy Brian look at those
guys very happy with his tits he's got a
good Jesus look at that [ __ ] caption
oh my God I didn't notice that police
doing the investigation must look at
that Captain yeah he did it the defense
stress your honor exhibit hey we're down
here thank you exhibit a and we rest our
case wow oh there you go it's a macho
guy Jesus
um yeah but so uh let's try and spice it
up here uh the uh I need more whiskey
I'm like but uh Indiana Jones they're
using uh uh computer animation to make
him look younger yeah they hate that
[ __ ] but it looks really it looks great
and I'll tell you I saw the trailer and
my daughter who's 10 looked at me and
she goes are you crying I go are you
still crying over India I I was like hey
get out
did you see one of these the computer
animated [ __ ] on that movie The Irish
garbage garbage it ruined the movie oh
my God the worst it was like why is
Robert De Niro have Down syndrome who
did this let me see this
so we can't play this part but no just
play it for us
oh I'm sucking I love it so did you use
the computer animated [ __ ] imagine you
come up Antonio Banderas like yeah so
don't worry about makeup was using
computers like for what
you know what
you think no I'm good just give me some
makeup
well what do you think of that column
all I'm thinking about is chat GPT you
won't shut up about well it's gonna be
so stupid okay no it's gonna [ __ ]
everything up I I mean have you it's
gonna [ __ ] you're not using Google
anymore
I mean it's it's no it's such a
disrupter so if you're did you like
Indiana Jones
let me get to it so
um do you know what chat GPT is no do
you me yeah we talked about it yeah but
have you let com have you actually gone
down the uh yeah bro it's it is it is
literally so if you're if you're if
you're in animation or if you're in your
writer if you're an animation if you're
in graphic design basically you're out
of a job if you write code I mean people
study code for it's it's no we don't
need you anymore
it's crazy as [ __ ] in it's thick it's
literally going to destroy entire swaths
of the economy and it's
it's in its infancy and it's already got
more users than any other platform
that's ever been used because it's it's
so out of control this guy was saying
this guy was literally said that it's so
extensive that you could type in
eventually right
found me
a billion dollar business find me found
fat BF I want to be a founder of a
billion dollars so create a billion
dollars it will go through
literally in Split seconds every
business plan every Harvard case study
every successful Venture and pull from
that and then find what product right
now is trending or what's needed or what
will be according to all the experts
hold on it'll it'll then
go out to a manufacturer and start
having that product made it will at the
same time come up with digital assets
for you well I'm finding my agent hold
on
listening there's a whole marketing
thing it does come up with videos for
you it'll then set your bank account up
it'll then set up an e-commerce yeah
that much but this is literally
what they're saying it's able to do hey
dude or it will be able to have to do
with Indiana
so I'm glad you asked I'm glad you asked
it will be something you can take that
script put the script into chat GPT and
it'll come up with another version of it
it'll come up with this so that one jobs
and then it'll take your characters and
say I want a young I want a young uh
Indiana Jones in this scene and it'll do
it for you
so I'm talking about something that has
its own intelligence that that builds
this thing out so quickly that
we're all out of a job now
hold on people are still going to see
they're still going to want to see live
performance but it's still going to go
to the movie theater but as far as like
worrying about special effects makeup we
got you we got you we can just hey I can
just do that that fast I want the real
guy no no don't worry about that the
real guy they're gonna make their now
you can make you can make people you can
just make people uh Composites of people
and they talk this is the Matrix but
it's [ __ ] okay so watch this
yes I'm a graphic designer yeah I'm a
graphic designer yeah sure [ __ ] out of
luck give me what do you want what do
you want me to give me something
anything you want me to do and make
right now tell me give me give me uh
circus all right a circus what would
give me some parameters around the
circus what do you want from you know
[ __ ] circus elephants you want
elephants I want a bearded lady you want
a bearded lady okay do you wanna you
wanna white chocolate unicorn maybe in
the distance no not stupid money just
I'm gonna put that in that bar and I go
like this I go send and it gives me 10
different versions
10 different versions then I go I want
it in Van Gogh and style of Van Gogh
yeah but um and it spits out 10
different books online it's like give me
actual animals at the circus no but but
it can now it can now give you any image
if you look at what it's doing with
virtual reality where it creates an
image that looks so real so [ __ ] real
that in just in its infancy in two years
you are not going to know the difference
between what is real and what is not
well hopefully they redo the Irishmen
is
the biggest disrupter since the printing
press why why why if its impact is going
to be so significant why am I only
hearing it because it just started
November 30th they can't get to the Dana
White news it just started November 30th
it's it's about a month old it's a month
November 22nd it said it came out yeah
it's uh I think November 30th and people
are using it uh it's got more users in
this short period of time than any any
interface ever it took 41 months for
Facebook to get up you know to where it
was and this is It's the [ __ ]
craziest disrupter of all time and to
the point where the designer the
designer a 37 year old man he just had
an open letter saying you don't have
some kind of universal basic income
we are going to be faced with the
greatest disrupter because there are
going to be entire take it down [ __ ]
face I got one hold on I can't anymore
have you ever seen Terminator 2. he said
I don't know what we're gonna do are you
a lawyers
you want medical advice okay you got a
disease of some kind yeah you just go to
Google and you'd go let me see what chat
hey what chat GPT will do is you you put
in this disease what it will do is take
anything that's been published ever how
does it know what's real or fake and it
it's information it knows it takes
anything that's been been peer-reviewed
any scientist that's ever published
anything or spoken about anything and
cleans all that information puts it and
then you say give me a simplified
version that I can understand and it'll
write it out not if Mark Zuckerberg gets
a hold of it well so the problem is
Google
is oh no he's not your Google is no good
here oh thank God I ain't using you oh
my God
but what if it's wrong what if it's
wrong so what if all the information it
calls and it gives you
the wrong outcome no the problem is that
that's not it's always right it's not
the problem I'm suing chat that's not
the problem are you saying chat or chat
chat are you say Chad chat chatter chat
chat
right there here's the big problem
schedule you put in how do I destroy the
planet with a hundred thousand dollars
it will come out with a list of how to
do that that's how you're gonna have to
make the bomb that's why AI has to stop
that
well who's going to regulate this Brian
that's the AI big [ __ ] problem so
what Elon Musk was one of the early
inventor uh investors said is he said
this is the biggest threat we face but
the way to solve it I don't care the way
to solve it is to have our own AI to
protect us from that AI yeah
but it is I'm going to say it again
November 30th things will that is a that
is a moment in history that may be the
most significant moment in all of our
lifetimes it is going to change
everything you're a lawyer this guy was
a lawyer he was a case study lawyer he
was uh he wrote about on on you know
he'd spent four years studying he's a
very well-known lawyer well-known lawyer
he spent like uh spent four years on uh
some kind of a tax policy that's really
hard ninja hold on I'm using it now ways
to end this conversation
he goes write me a paper on this on
these with these parameters it was
better than anything he'd written in
four years and it happened in one minute
or less what the [ __ ] how old is he if
you're in college and you want to write
us a paper you want to write a paper
give me the subject doesn't matter what
it is Irish home rule will they all be
different though like if you and I are
let's say we're both in college many
years ago and we're like man we get this
paper done we can just type dancing you
have two different variations yeah
here's what's my teacher's my dude oh
it's not your vocal oh here's what's
even more [ __ ] up you say write it in
my in my words using you mean misspell
things using the kinds of words I use
write it in my voice throwing a few Bros
write it in my voice yeah write it in my
voice Jordan Peterson tried this he goes
he put in he goes I want I want maps of
meaning but I want you to
cross-pollinate the Dao de Jing and
[ __ ] I'm out and something else and
it did it and it did and he was like and
it wasn't bad
wait Are we more afraid of this or the
robot
this is the robots bro
this is going to be robots they're going
to have access to all the skills yeah
they're going to build a house you just
have to buy the land and they'll build a
house and they'll mine they they'll mine
the actual materials right there on site
for you so that they will make it there
yeah and they'll build it for you and
it'll be really it's like oh where it's
it's it is Gonna Change
everything and people don't realize it's
a tidal wave it's like you know it's a
tidal wave
people know it's a tidal wave right yeah
I know yeah but you guys didn't know
who's next no I know who in the media is
talking about it then why is it why is
nobody addressing everybody is other
than no everybody is actually talking
about it but it's like it's nobody stops
dive in nobody saw this coming nobody
saw nobody saw this kind of disruption
Elon saw it though right yeah this is
that's what he's been warning about this
is the kind of disruption that actually
the Genies out of the bottle and our
lives and everything we know was going
to be different I'm telling you it's
gonna happen in one year it's a plot of
high robot but yeah I hear you it's it's
all right Brian what do we do dude this
is the worst news than anything
you got all I want to know if you're
gonna see [ __ ] Indiana learn how to
make it work for you we have to figure
out how to actually reliable have you
asked at anything not yet I'm afraid
what are you waiting to ask I'm gonna
put my my whole my I mean I have some
ideas
it can it's an open open language AI has
anybody profited off of it yet has
anybody done something where there's
Real Results where somebody says the
answer to that is yes that's how I got
this studio yes
but beside the investigating and selling
businesses uh off of this yeah but how
dope would it be if like you marketing
Foreign
Tour dates in these cities
well this guy created a a YouTube video
and I was watching it and I was like
well well I mean you need the days of
shooting things and the days of editing
that's adorable the days of like I mean
it's unbelievable the days of that are
one person can do a a a YouTube video
that'll blow your socks I hate this
world it's unbelievable well I think
what it's going to do is give the
individual the craziest amount of
everybody's a genius everybody's Jeremy
I don't know yeah because yes they can
go to their phone and ask anything and
get instant results and solves and
solutions yeah and profit from it so
what's going to make us stick out like
where's the hours yeah so the outliers
are going to be the ones that ask the
best questions the outlier is going to
be the ones that are able to create a
platform on top of this platform right
so the the the biggest thing is you're
gonna say well I gotta go shoot this
commercial I gotta hire a camera crew I
gotta hire editors and they and somebody
will go no you don't
um just put it in chat TP how when you
need to buy in five minutes I'll do that
for you right now there are people that
are going to be able to do that and are
doing that now and it's in it we're in
chat GPT one when we get to chat GPT 100
I'm sorry are you saying Chad or chat
chat God damn it because the guy who
created his chat it's no the guy who
created it was a Sam Altman I believe
bring up Sam Altman guy's name is Chad
so two people okay to use this thing
it's a [ __ ] genius yeah you got to
pay for like the previous so the company
that's the guy the company is open okay
boxed his hair I'm saying about him he's
a genius hey Chad did you wake him up
that's that might I don't want to piss
that guy off don't don't pick a fight
Bubba be cool be cool now all you do is
how do I cancel someone the fastest
I mean dude it's nuts well you [ __ ] this
now now he wants to make the world a
better place well he doesn't clearly
doesn't well he said that he's the one
warning he's the one saying look this
this has to be handled this is going to
destroy entire swaths of our and he's
American
yes he is and he in your face Russia yep
he's a gay he's a gay American man it's
a gay man yep wow he's a genius he's a
[ __ ] genius oh it has to be and he
already had started a company where he
sold it for 43 million dollars but this
is beyond 37 is from Chicago went to
Stanford then puts dropped out yeah he's
like oh this isn't this is this is easy
all right yeah right this is easy loser
unbelievable insane dude he's a genius
well he [ __ ] us but yeah well if he
didn't come up with it Russia or China
would nowhere well China's working on it
but China's so worried about it that
they have what they've said is that but
you are not allowed they use it then
well so China said you're not allowed
yeah they're they're trying to
capitalize on this right now they're
doing that
China is saying you cannot as a Chinese
citizen you cannot be involved in this
unless you have unless you can't be
anonymous on this you have to give us
your name and address because we need to
know where you are you know you but the
problem is you get some Evil Genius
who's like how do I how do I destroy
enjoy the planet in six easy steps
there are there's there's information
out there on how to build dirty bombs on
how to do all kinds of things
dark web anything that's like so
anything that's been anything that's
been on the internet up until 2021
anything Bubba
anything it is a true Matrix anything
is available and it will get it for you
this fast and then you can you haven't
used it said how do I fix my teeth
without Invisalign well you should look
at that because the good thing is
scientifically discovering scientific
discovery is going to be uh multiplied
by about a thousand that's the good news
there are he thinks that we're going to
have so much free time to do the things
we want to do no no no I haven't slept
hey [ __ ] you're free wait I haven't
slept in three days and I call those
jobs are gonna be fine I called my
friends that are in in this world like
big time in this world I do have these
friends Chad world yeah I do chat you
know you have no friends in chat I have
I have friends I have friends since
November I have friends in Tech and in
in in math and in physics big big time
people and all of them are like nobody's
sleeping
nobody says they're worried they're not
gonna have jobs
they're worried that it is what the
Unabomber was warning us about
have you read his Manifesto no wait
what's up what besides killing people
legit points hey Steve keep eating your
McDonald's because yeah dude this is Sir
this is I I grew your last time I called
the people that I know that handle so I
have family members that that have
stocks and bonds and stuff like that and
I said you got to educate yourself on
this because you you own pieces of
companies that might go Belly Up in a
day if you're not careful at 88 years
old
well you got to know this stuff because
it's going to be it's there's I people
this much smarter than I am I don't
follow this but when I hear people that
are really smart saying this is the
biggest disrupter
we've ever faced
I go what huh I thought he was gonna
have good news we were all no I haven't
we got out of it doing the in yeah yeah
and you're like somebody's saying
Indiana Jones
if you're a coder you don't need to be
anymore it codes for you I know it's
that name of jobs man you're stressing
everybody out I'm so stressed about it
but well I don't give a [ __ ] for comics
for Comics human beings it might be even
more for us as Things become more
virtual people want to see a human being
in front of them they don't want to
actually just go together replicate yeah
yeah live music
yeah there's Holograms this is very
depressing yeah it can write stand up I
heard that you can write stand up it can
write how much fire was Burt Chrysler
show did talk about Armageddon are we
done you can't even you're turning your
back on it no the whole world can't turn
your back on the Brian the whole world
don't turn your back an eye out why
would Steve even come in you guys are a
couple
who gives a [ __ ] you guys are put you
all stop you're putting your heads in
the sand it all searches chat D Pete
we'll we'll write my next special GPT
what is it called chat GPT will Chad
tell me how to manage my fish can we ask
yourself something right now yeah can we
ask it something right now I think you
gotta pay yeah it's free to sign up but
you give up I heard you have a bunch of
information away and I don't want to do
that yeah you have to give away like
your first book no no you don't uh Nick
did it no yeah we did on uh yeah you
just sign up the way you do for me Gmail
go ahead and sign up let's use your
information they already know but they
already know it I don't I'm not gonna
put mine they already know it you
already I love how you think your data
is not everywhere it's everywhere but I
don't want to sign up for is what I'm
saying oh you're down gotta look into
them yeah I'm not I don't trust it I
don't trust Chad at this point
it's the only thing to be thinking about
hey
yeah are you a cold lead hey hey and it
writes are you Chad it writes it writes
[ __ ] it writes hey shut up man scram
place
we've already been over it dude what are
we gonna do I don't give a [ __ ] dude how
about that you just gonna ignore it hey
hey
no dude can that database suck my [ __ ]
well now you're gonna happen I'm glad
you brought up porno I'm glad you
brought up porn because Chad GPT oh my
God [ __ ] you yeah name any business
Brian we I know we get it Steve What's
it gonna do in porn
digital oh you like Jenna James 17.
you're mine yeah ask me the question
again What's it gonna do with porn
anything you want except big black dicks
and that's the business I'm investing in
only big black dicks your move Chad
you uh dude you are going to be arrested
tonight
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go home my kids
are like Dad can have candy whatever the
[ __ ] you want dude the world's ending
according to your Uncle Brian this Chad
guy I looked at my one-year-old I go I
don't know what world you're going to
step into
it just sounds overwhelmingly depressing
yeah title is very positive about it
there are a lot of people that are like
this is the greatest thing well no our
lives are gonna be incredible but it's
like everybody no because AI is going to
always for us that we don't have to do
for ourselves and it'll free us up to be
more creative it'll free us up to do the
things we really want to do so that's
the bright but but everybody now yeah
everybody is on an equal plane
that's so even the dumbass exactly
that's the point that's lazy can put in
right jokes like Steve so expertise and
all that stuff let's chat then there
they are they're there that's Chad
that's chat GPT
don't make him angry here's my thing
[ __ ] Chad [ __ ] Tesla electric cars I
don't like any of it I know but it's
here no I'll fight it resistance is here
your kung fu no no it's gonna be the
outliers the people that don't use it oh
I know um your kung fu is no good
someone's like oh Chad wrote that no
actually I wrote that and then I go it
was like oh my oh
Chad wrote mine so you write it and I go
like this I put it in I put yours in and
I go right this bit better and disguise
it as mine
so there's no there's nobody regulating
this thing other than the the individual
open AI is regulating it so they they're
very aware they're very aware that
people will say um how do I create this
weapon how do I how do I get away with
murder all that and how do I kill Brian
Collins so that that's going to be
something that they monitor so they say
yeah but good luck with that so they say
good luck but then the AI is going to be
embedded within the AI
you know the AI is protecting itself
from itself this is can we go back to
George Lopez yeah because it doesn't
matter how you got [ __ ] over by Coney
what's the larger implication is the
only person they just understand this is
Chris Christopher Nolan because he wrote
Inception and he's the only one that can
understand the biggest
mindset the biggest mind [ __ ] is that if
they're able to do this with AI and you
can create images that are impossible to
detect whether they're real or not right
so already they can do deep fakes where
they had Obama making 14 14 different
speeches or the the Obama making a
speech and which of the 14 is fake the
the trick answer was they were all fake
and they looked real yes wait this came
out recently yes it's all it's all fake
but it looked real it's gonna ruin the
internet well the problem is the problem
is that's that's GPT one
what is gbt 100 now hold on if if it's
that real why do you think that this is
real why do you think this isn't a
[ __ ] computer program right this
talking because I'm not [ __ ] Brian
[ __ ] you and Chad please don't use the r
word
[Applause]
how do I know that that's just not okay
are you doing mushrooms again nope
no so how do we know any of us are real
both of you
you're going to do the Deep dive and
you're not going to be the same I'm not
I'm gonna wait for somebody else to do
the work I can't dive into it and give
me the the chat for dummies I'm like yep
yep yep I needed to spread my misery
because I'm a mess it is depressing
hearing how much fun was bird show I'm
so so it was a total blast I'm so sorry
yeah absolute blast I'm gonna watch that
yeah just to have fun you sure it was
real murdering domestic violence the
world's gonna end man it's been great
being here guys I hated on Indiana Jones
we're all excited about I [ __ ] up
didn't I hey dude
your take on Dana was awful you know I
just Steve's crying get him an apple get
him in that boy it was Dave Rubin wrong
don't burn this country no let's burn it
after hearing Brian Cowan yeah I can get
a summary of that book right now on chat
gbt sure well why even bother wearing
books anyway well that's an interesting
question it's not though no
yeah well that's the end of this show go
watch go watch Steve's uh special it's
probably the last one that Chad's not
gonna write yeah it's uh and it might
not even be me
it's not really me how do I know it's
not me you're Ontario Improv great club
uh this weekend Ontario Improv 5th
through the seventh then you're in
Fairfield theater stage one Fairfield
Connecticut then you're at the 3C Bull
in uh New York where's that at Teresa
Teresa New York yeah and then the Jimmy
Kimmel comedy club in Vegas Funny Bone
Cincinnati uh punchline Atlanta great
club and then uh Jimmy you're back at
Jimmy Kimmel's Comedy Club Can't Get
Enough breakdown Comedy Club great one
February 10th through 11th Funny Bone
Syracuse oh you're grinding boy you're
back in Vegas again yeah I'm doing a
residency so it's every other Thursday
um yeah I don't know I'm start I'm gonna
do a
I don't want to just do a show yeah like
I just don't it's like Vegas so I'm
gonna do a show called New Year Steve
where every show you come to we ring in
the New Year
that's [ __ ] great so we're gonna have
the LED screen we're gonna do a
countdown and we're gonna celebrate New
Year's every night at 12 o'clock uh it
could be 8 55. yeah it's up to Chad
that's Chad decided to tell me what time
it is up to chat chat D yeah and you
guys are going to be in trouble for
calling chat GPT Chad's just so much it
just rings off the tongue I'm so I'm so
afraid come up with that I'm so afraid I
don't shut up about it would you just
shut up your Piper for it all right I
don't want to go to Vegas I'm in Vegas
this weekend
if you're going to talk to me about Chad
don't come it's January 5th through the
7th that's this Thursday Friday Saturday
Wise Guys Vegas and then I close the
month in Tampa January 20th and 21st
Tampa Florida uh Tampa Improv and then
first week of February Springfield
Missouri and a bunch of other dates on
there I guess get your tickets to
thickboy.com if you want that sweet uh
nectar that Chad's gonna make a better
uh whiskey get your tiger thick whiskey
before Chad makes his own San Diego
California my drop Comedy Club January 5
6 and 7. that's Thursday tomorrow Friday
Saturday might drop new comedy club in
San Diego I'm excited Fort Wayne Indiana
Summit Comedy Club January 13 14. that's
a Friday Saturday in Fort Wayne Indiana
Dania Florida Dania improv January 19
2021 Edmonton Canada I'll see you at the
comic strip February 23 24 25. cool
Steve we love you man go outside thank
you very much Amazon Prime right now one
of the best doing it Steve we love you
buddy love you guys thank you so much
sorry about the whole Channel your
special is [ __ ] awesome thank you my
friend yeah we'll try it man love you
guys this is uh I love you guys sorry